I'm really excited about the show
tonight yes baby I love it
I can't believe we've never been here
before I know out of all the basement
one of the only basis I haven't been
awful I guess we get to meet the I get
to make the generator oh yeah
excited about that what if they're gonna
let me flat black hawk I doubt it
you never could
make general Ingrid when I met the
general I shook his hand of course and
then it just felt natural to just give
him a hug I think he was a little
startled because I don't think that
generals walk around hugging everybody
you know because they you know they
they're the general so welcome to him
for Raleigh it's the home of the first
century division the oldest and the most
prestigious division United States Army
first to fight in World War one first to
fight World War two first to fight in
Vietnam
what an honor awesome thank you so much
we're excited about the show Fort
Raleigh has true history it's it's
really incredible I just got back from
Iraq but before that I went to the d-day
invasion the 70th anniversary oh I feel
like a loser
oh how you done nothing with my life
look at what these people do I write
songs yeah if you look at the home all
Beach there's a huge minor moral to the
first entry on the bottom that's their
mission to difficult no static Christ
agree now you'll hear is say that lot in
the song and the division song we have
be great you singing division Sal I'm
nervous
I've never heard the song I don't know
the song if you started singing tonight
everybody would stamps you got to come
into position of attention you start
selling songs the band will play it you
just come out and I give you to work
general asks you to do something you got
it do it yeah you don't have an option
nah I mean yes I'm not gonna say no no
don't say no yeah no he's a gentleman
yeah yeah everybody will snap
disposition retention stand up do it